quels enjeux derrière cette tournée
consacrée à la crise ukrainienne
pourquoi le chef de la diplomatie
américaine appelle moscou à choisir la
voie diplomatique tout en accordant un
soutien financier de 100 millions de
dollars à kiev une communication calculé
deux jours d'un face-à-face russo
américain c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous ce soir pour en parler sur
ce plateau régis le sommier grand
reporter rt france bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous en direct également
pour nous accompagner au gène berg
ancien diplomate français spécialiste de
la russie ainsi que karine bêcher vous
l'offre au professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou bonsoir à
tous les deux merci d'être avec nous on
l'a entendu avec vera goffman antonymes
d'yquem qui appelle les nuire poutine à
choisir la voie pacifique dans le même
temps les états unis qui a engagé des
moyens supplémentaires envers l'ukraine
tout en n'ayant peut-être aussi
certaines manoeuvres à la frontière
ukrainienne on a du mal à comprendre ce
qu'on est au bord d'une grève d'une
guerre concrètement en ukraine régis
selon moi je ne le crois pas je pense
que en revanche ce qui est en train de
se passer en ce moment et ce qui se
passe plus globalement depuis deux mois
provoque une virée une une commande hier
un renforcement d'une sorte de
bilatéralisme dans le monde avec ce
retour de la russie qui a quand même il
faut le reconnaître bien réussi son coup
dans le sens est là elle dialogue à
nouveau directement avec les américains
on sent que les européens sont écartés
ce dialogue d'ailleurs on l'a vu un les
pourparlers qui ont eu lieu pendant ces
dernières semaines ont eu lieu donc
entre armagnacs off ça nous a rappelé un
petit peu les époques l'époque de la
guerre de syrie notamment de la bataille
d'alep où on voyait à l'époque c'était
kerry lavrov qu'on voyait en permanence
qui s'étaient substitués d'ailleurs
presque à leur chef d'état obama et
poutine à l'époque et il y avait pour la
question du règlement de la question
syrienne un face à face américains et
russes là on est dans la même une
configuration où justement cette
rencontre entre sergueï lavrov et
anthony blinken a geneve peu pour moi
considère être considérée comme un point
positif pour la russie puisque la russie
a réussi à être entendus et ella elle
l'a imposé il faut le reconnaître un
agenda assez comment assez osée sur
l'ukraine demandant et exigent de la
part de l'otan
des engagements sur le fait que
l'ukraine et la géorgie
n'adhéreront jamais à l'otan le reste
tout autour c'est chacun montre ses
muscles chacun
montre à l'autre qu'il est capable
d'influencer qu'il est capable qu'il a
des alliés pour l'otan on le voit c'est
ses propos sur ces informations sur la
présence de nouveaux commande de deux
nouveaux comment de nouvelles livraisons
d'armes notamment de la part des
britanniques et autres on sait que voilà
de part et d'autre il ya 7 7 une manière
de se jauger mutuellement mais c'est
surtout sur le front diplomatique que
russie amérique ont repris une certaine
façon chacun son intérêt je termine là
dessus les haies des états unis ont tout
intérêt de à reprendre mondialement une
sorte de leadership et a montré qu'elle
le sentiment d'affaiblissement qu'on
avait vu notamment à travers la crise
afghane et le le retrait désastreux e
d'afghanistan et puis la russie a
intérêt à montrer qu'aujourd'hui elle
est un partenaire incontournable qu'elle
a grandi sur la scène internationale et
qu'aujourd'hui il faut compter avec elle
le jeune bergues vous avez le même type
d'analysé on est finalement dans les
postures on n'oublie pas de joe biden à
des élections de mi-mandat qui approche
à grands pas au final la russie a réussi
une forme de rapports de force en
s'imposant comme une forme de deux
partenaires égal aux etats unis c'est
votre lecture également oui c'est ma
lecture tout à fait mais j'aimerais
quand même la nuance est ou plutôt
ajouter
à la balise qui est tout à fait
pertinent de monsieur le sommier bon
vous l'avez dit vous-même il ya un côté
politique interne il ya quand même deux
millions
craignent un proche de craignent qu'ils
sont des citoyens américains ou qui sont
des électeurs et un million et demi au
canada et effectivement devant le mythe
terme dont on va pas parler des états
unis mais ça rentre en compte puisqu'il
y aura des mi-terme joba eden est très
affaibli critiquer mais il donc ils
pêchent vois ça c'est la première raison
la seconde c'est vrai que les états unis
resserrent les rangs ils ont besoin de
resserrer les rangs de rang de montrer
qu'ils sont indispensables que sans eux
ya pas de qualité européennes et par
ricochet ils vont créer des obligés en
disant écoutez on vous a aidé vis-à-vis
de soi disant l'ours russe qui vous
menace nous sommes pour protéger et en
échangeant va demander eh bien on va
vous demander d'adopter notre position
du réserves de la chine là pas question
de vous défilez ça vous verrez écouter
dans quelques mois ça va paraître les
effectifs alors la troisième
effectivement j'ai observé ça presque à
la loupe jour par jour je trouve que les
américains et les anglo saxons je peins
pas de la france et d'allemagne en font
trop et c'est là que combat déséquilibré
autant les russes soit disant été
menaçants par la presse occidentale qui
n'était pas du tout orienté pro moscou
au contraire et là qu'est ce qu'on a
avant de négocier qu'est ce qu'ils font
bon il ya toutes ses livraisons
d'armements sans entrer dans le détail
chiffré les états unis ont livré 3
milliards de dollars d'armements c'est
la moitié du budget craignant il n'y a
pas beaucoup de pays où la moitié du
budget ben israel ne reçoit que le car
l'ukraine bon évidemment si s'étaler sur
plusieurs années il ya également un
projet de base à perdre yank vous
regarderez prennent la mer d'azov où les
anglais veulent créer une base militaire
tout près du détroit car je vois les
choses comme ça c'est pas c'est pas le
meilleur moment de négocier dans le
calme dans la concentration
là vraiment oui il ya on en fait trop
d'un côté qui est vraiment qui est
excessif par rapport à l'or alors on
verra si tout ça dégonflé dans les jours
à venir il faut le souhaiter mais c'est
comme préoccupant parce que les
accusations monte et il ya un espèce de
rideau de fumée autour de ces
négociations et ça ça crée un sentiment
d'instabilité de peur et donc c'est pas
très favorable à des négociations calme
où on doit discuter calmement comme ça a
été le cas dans le passé donc c'est
quand même un petit peu préoccupant et
il faut souhaiter eu ce jeu ne va pas
trop continuer car on voit quand même
que la russie peine à convaincre un de
ses bonnes intentions en tout cas de ne
pas avoir de mauvaises intentions avant
de vous donner la parole je voudrais
vous faire écouter peut être une voie un
petit peu dissonante en france bruno
dredd ce qui met deux conférences à
l'inalco sur justement l'intérêt
qu'aurait la russie a entre guillemets
envahir le cred je ne pense pas que la
russie est en ce moment vraiment intérêt
à prendre le contrôle de l'ukraine vu la
situation économique de l'ukraine je
pense en revanche que la russie fait
pression pour avoir des négociations
globales l'ukraine étant qu'un élément
dans le jeu international pour les
russes il s'agit de rétablir un
équilibre entre la russie les états unis
et l'otan l'ukraine n'est qu'un terrain
d'exercice parmi d'autres un des
premiers terrain d'exercice entre les
deux superpuissances
c'est vrai que car ils n'avaient chez
google go quand on entend c'est vrai les
médias en france j'entendais encore
revoilà nos confrères de france info
hier soir s'exprimer sur ce même dossier
on n'a pas cette voie là on est persuadé
des mauvaises intentions russes en la
matière pour quelles raisons selon vous
est-ce aussi compliqué pour moscou de
convaincre
c'est difficile pour moscou de
convaincre parce que la pénétration du
discours ou plus dans le discours
médiatique globale est beaucoup plus
faible que la pénétration du discours
global dans le discours us donc à partir
de l'oeil un certain déséquilibre
surtout qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas
oublier quand même que le combat qui se
mène semaine sur deux plans sur plan de
la communication d'une part mais
également sur plan du réel sur plan de
la communication on voit effectivement
comme intervenants l'ont déjà souligné
les neuf remontée en puissance de la
rhétorique
mais qui cache aussi assez mal en fait
une absence de volonté de mener une
guerre réelle ce qui finalement n'est
peut-être pas mal quand même
on voit effectivement des livraisons
d'armes l'on voit effectivement à
une puce et agressive mais je suis assez
d'accord avec mr yaakov il y a quand
même très très peu de chances pour que
cela débouche sur un véritable conflit
armé globale comme nous en avons déjà
connu par le passé en revanche il y
existe déjà actuellement un véritable
conflit y est en ce sens
il est vrai que le conflit ukrainiens et
ce que l'on appelle un conflit
secondaire le conflit primaires c'est ce
conflit entre d'une part cette vision
globaliste qui impose un seul centre de
pouvoir un seul centriste de décision
les états unis et le retour de bail des
nains et des démocrates à la présidence
l'a affirmé dès le départ ce sont les
états unis qui reprennent ce rôle de
leader contre à la vision de la russie
qui est une vision multipolaire qui ne
veut pas dire le retour aux
états-nations puisqu'il s'agit de paul
ney qui suppose en tout cas l'existence
de plusieurs centres décision politique
et c'est ce combat primaire qui est
fondamental aujourd'hui dans les
relations russo américaines qui explique
les différents terrains sur lesquels se
réalise ensuite de façon régional les on
va dire les rapports de force qu'on peut
créer militaire il n'y a pas que
d'ukraine il a eu aussi la syrie et ne
faut pas l'oublier parce que en syrie
aussi le retour de la russie a été
fondamental et ça a été la première très
grosse défaite du plan atlantiste
puisqu'à partir du moment où sur demande
des autorités syriennes la russie est
intervenue dans la contre le terrorisme
l'on a vu se renverser le rapport de
force entre les groupes terroristes et
les forces syriennes régulière donc il a
effectivement c'est ce décalage entre
d'une part un discours qui est qui monte
en puissance
mais à côté de ça on ne sent pas quand
même une réalité de volonté dit d'une
part ni de l'autre d'entrer dans un
conflit militaire massif un traditionnel
quant à la question de la volonté d'
invasion de de l'ukraine par la russie
c'était assez amusant quand même et
sincèrement franchement grotesque
surtout de le voir répéter comme ça
presque comme un mantra presque tous les
jours par les différends à
l'autorité politique occidentale qui
d'une certaine manière cherche à
formater un discours qui va essayer de
recréer de légitimer leur plan d'action
qui est ce qu'on trouvait mais c'est
vrai quand vous êtes trois intervenants
je voudrais c'est de distribuer la
parole équitablement sur ce plateau en
tout cas anthony blinken poursuit lui sa
sa tournée direction l'allemagne demain
avant genève alors pas en france on
n'aura pas la chance de voir le
secrétaire d'état américain en france
pourtant emmanuel macron a tenu à
s'exprimer sur le sujet aujourd'hui lors
de son tout premier discours devant le
parlement européen première orale dans
la peau du président du conseil de
l'union européenne je vous propose
justement de l'écouter sur ce dossier
ces prochaines semaines doivent nous
conduire à faire aboutir une proposition
européenne
bâtissant un nouvel ordre de sécurité et
de stabilité
nous devons le construire entre
européens puis le partager avec nos
alliés dans le cadre de l'otan et
ensuite le proposer à la négociation à
la russie alors c'est vrai régis le
sommier cette crise ukrainienne à
l'arrêt vd cette faiblesse d'une défense
européenne ya urgence sur ce sujet elle
a révélé une faiblesse c'est surtout une
absence des européens on a bien compris
que quand les premiers pourparlers ont
eu lieu entre eux
joe biden et vladimir poutine
immédiatement bon job hayden c1 dépêcher
d'en parler avant et après d'informer
ses alliés mais parce qu'il y avait une
manière de justement de 2,2 les insectes
joe biden avait été donc critiqué sur
l'afghanistan et sur la question du
contrat des sous marins australiens
donna d'avoir complètement piétiner ses
alliés ce qui a été la réalité est là on
a remarqué que les américains voulaient
embarquer les européens simplement les
russes nous ne sont pas d'accord et que
l'on vladimir poutine l'a dit il a dit
que les européens n'étaient pas assez
indépendant alors peut-être qu'il y
at-il dans ledit de le message des
manuels macron qui est très important
parce que c'est la première fois qu'un
pays de l'otan à une position prom
promeut comment king qui ne promeut qui
ne met pas l'otan en avant directement
mais l'union européenne l'union
européenne dont on a parlé c'est bien
cela s'entend mais il a eu du mal à
réaliser mais façon la défense
européenne elle est toujours au point
mort même si elle donne lieu à des
débats régulièrement mon service a
ressuscité ont dit oui tiens il faudrait
qu'elle compense est immédiatement
d'ailleurs vous avez comment comme le
secrétaire de l'otan qui dit non il ya
déjà l'otan n'y a pas besoin de des
poutres défense européenne en gros c'est
ce qu'on entend à chaque fois là
emmanuel macron à une musique un petit
peu différente de celle d' anthony
blinken et des américains il ya le fait
il a pris acte que les américains et les
russes dialogue face à face sans les
européens et lui veut proposer autre
chose peut-être parce que la france
justement est à la tête de l'union
européenne etc pour marquer aussi une
différence mais c'est peut-être aussi
pour marquer une un peut-être un
réajustement dans les rapports entre
l'union européenne et la russie eugène
dingue comment vous l'avez perçu ce
discours un d'emmanuel macron concernant
les crises ukrainienne est justement le
rapport face à la russie alors je les
examiner attentivement puisque je vais
donner un cours de ma là dessus alors
bon il n'y a pas de défense européenne
s'est entendue on va pas faire un cours
théorique là dessus
il n'y a pas d'art il n'ya pas d'armée
européenne n'y a pas d'état major
européen il n'y a pas de force
d'intervention sauf pour les petites
choses qu'on doit au sahel ça si tu n'es
une histoire qui dure depuis disons 60
ans alors par contre avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour mon président
donc je trouve que le discours est très
général par les deux ordres on va tout
le monde parle de l'ordre et j'ai
examiné il dit absolument rien de
nouveau il parle là aussi il dit qu'il
faut pas menacée l'intérêt de
l'intérieur c'est l'article 2 alinéa 4
de l'onu il dit qu'on a le droit de
rentrer dans les alliances et l'article
52 de la charte quand il dit que c'est
des principes c'est des vieux principe
le seul problème d'achoppement c'est
effectivement est-ce que l'ukraine a le
droit ou non d'adhérer à l'otan ça c'est
le point de friction il faudra bien que
les diplômes à des deux côtés trouvent
un compromis pour l'instant c'est
beaucoup plus théorique parce que
personne de sérieux ne veut que
l'ukraine rentrer dans le temps et
pareil la géorgie c'est un et je crois
qu'il faudrait écarter ce problème de
négociation et examiner tous les autres
problèmes
c'est à dire la réduction des tensions
le fait qu'on armes pas qu'on ne menace
pas l'autre pays par rapport à
territoire et ainsi de suite donc son
tente sur les manoeuvres c'est ce
système de mesures de confiance qui ont
été faits pendant la guerre froide qu'il
faut mettre en oeuvre et assez vite et
je répète sans élever la voix et il faut
espérer que sergueï lavrov et anthony
brendel conservant à genève entamant ces
discussions on a eu des préliminaires au
niveau les hauts fonctionnaires on aura
maintenant les ministres et le veut
c'est que on arrive à négocier et qu'on
arrive à des résultats substantiels
avant le mois de juin avant le sommet de
l'otan où le cren pour être invité
c'est là la priorité du jour il faut
vraiment aller vite et sortir ce langage
un petit peu martial et négocier avec
vraiment avec compétence avec sérieux et
avec vraiment volonté d'aboutir si
effectivement on n'a pas cette volonté
d'aboutir on aura on n'aura pas des
affrontements guerrier mais on aura une
absence d' échanges économiques on aura
des restrictions aux échanges humains et
on aura un problème de régression dans
le domaine de la stabilité de l'ordre le
rang au sens le plus large oui on sent
effectivement pour la russie c'est une
ligne rouge en le c7 cette adhésion à
l'otan knbc gobomgo vous pensez que les
russes vont avoir gain de cause il
demande cet engagement ça tarde à venir
vous y croyez vous à cet engagement de
la part des occidentaux et des
américains notamment
il semblerait que bien contraire macron
et était justement très très clair sur
la question et qu'il a entièrement
repris la position américaine donc là
dessus ça règle la question de
l'autonomie une politique étrangère de
l'union européenne et d'une question de
défense indépendant de l'otan puisque
finalement très clairement il a expliqué
que non que si l'otan décident
d'intégrer d'ukraine elle le pourra
c'est exactement ce qu'il a dit
lorsqu'il a soulevé la question de la
possibilité d'intégrer de nouveaux états
de la même manière et d'attaquer
critères extrêmement la position russe
quand il a parlé de la question la
défense de l'intégrité territoriale
puisque du point de vue atlantiste le
fait que la crimée après un référendum
et après la chute de l'état this it et
en ukraine suite au coup d'état du
maidan et été rattachée à l'ukraine est
considéré comme une atteinte à
l'intégrité territoriale du craignait
donc en fait ma tron a été extrêmement
clairs merci oui à tous les trois régis
le sommier karine d'échec au logo et
j'aime bien merci d'avoir été avec nous
savoir apporter votre analyse et on le
disait